this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you for that introduction uh so
I'm here to talk about some of the work
that I've been doing uh trying to
understand and map freezing tolerance
and and cold tolerance in uh Trips Again
and more specifically talk about some of
the the challenges that we've kind of
been running into with uh doing this
mapping in a in a heterozygous genome
and so to kind of motivate the whole
thing really in the end what the the
whole goal is is to as we'd like to be
able to plant Maize earlier extend the
growing season and to do that we kind of
need freezing tolerance and the logic
behind that is if we look at uh
miscanthus's biomass accumulation
relative to Maize so these plots on the
right
black is miscanthus white is maze uh by
the end of miscanthus's growing season
it accumulates about 60 more biomass
but the the below plots showing the
rates of accumulation of the tooth are
pretty comparable
so it seems like really the the big dis
difference there is that miscanthus just
starts its season earlier and ends it
later and so the thought is if we can
replicate that in maze as well we may be
able to increase biomass there and that
may translate to yield increases
and so trypticum now matters because uh
it's a grass relative that persists in a
pretty wide latitude latitudinal range
exposed to a lot of different
environmental conditions so really warm
environments and environments where it
gets really cold it's also a perennial
so it must be exhibiting some kind of
freezing tolerance since that it since
it survives Winters and then also it's a
very close relative of maize having
diverged only about a half million years
ago and it shares a whole genome
duplication event
and so to kind of try to uh
approach understanding and mapping this
freezing tolerance Denise costich and
Nick Le Peck in the lab put together
this mapping population that consists of
a number of families that are Northern
by Southern trypscomb crosses uh those
f1s from those crosses were all planted
in a field together and open pollinated
and Seed was collected from from those
f1s for further screens
and so then Christy Galt a former lab
member
um
went ahead and took that seed that was
collected from those f1s
germinated them to seedlings exposed
them to freezing conditions
visually phenotyped for tolerance and
susceptibility and then those bulks
tolerant susceptible were pulled
together DNA extracted and then
furthermore uh
we also did some alumina whole genome
sequencing for all of those Founders for
that population all of the f1s and then
each one of those pulled bolts
and so from there
now we have a lot of sequencing data
that that should represent the genetics
of of this population and we want to
actually do some mapping and so
initially there were some attempts to do
this mapping using maze reference genome
uh as the as a reference to map two this
didn't work mostly well because
the two genomes are just a very uh have
differences in in their architecture so
mace has 10 chromosomes trypscomb has
18. so there's a lot of issues with just
antiguity there and then also there's
always the possibility that whatever
genes are in trypscomb that are
contributing to freeze intolerance just
aren't in Maze and so there's a few
different aspects
that could be benefited by just using a
trypscomb reference genome to map2 and
so through the pan and project there was
sampling of a couple trypscomb uh
of the trypscomb founders and those were
sequenced with packed by hi-fi
uh and and I tried mapping using those
genomes uh and that didn't work uh but
uh it worked didn't work for a different
reason this time thankfully
um and so the the issue in this case is
that the genomes are really good so uh
since this was sequenced with packed by
a HiFi you get really long really high
accurate reads uh the assemblers are
actually able to put together these
heterozygous regions and and capture all
the haplotypes that are or all the
alleles that are present in that genome
in that individual and so those are kind
of handled in two different ways during
assembly in one instance you can have
just one main haplotype that kind of
goes across
and then any like heterozygous regions
will kind of be bowled off into these
smaller scaffolds and in this case it's
really easy to get to a a single
haplotype because you can just filter by
size of the sequence
um but then the other situation which
seems to be the one that we're kind of
running into here or that I'm running
into is that um you get like pretty much
full representation of both haplotypes
um homozygous regions are represented in
both scaffolds and so just using
something like uh scaffold size isn't
really a good metric to to filter out
haplotypes and like maybe you're
thinking okay so you have all this
allelic diversity that's in your
reference genome why would that really
be a problem that seems like a good
thing that you're capturing all these
alleles and the issue is well it is a
great thing but uh for our purposes or
my purpose it makes things a lot more
complicated in that
what I'm trying to do is take reads that
represent some other individual other
trips come map them to this genome and
identify variants in that genome and in
the case where we have multiple alleles
like on the right here what ends up
happening is you get re the reads will
just map to whichever
copy of that Gene they're more similar
to and so the first issue is that you're
splitting you're like reducing your
depth in half pretty much for your
sequencing and so you have a lot less
power to like well depending on how you
handle it um
but the bigger issue is that you miss
all these heterozygous calls
um
so say the uh for that site the
reference genome has both copies uh
has the same uh alleles as the
individual that you're mapping to it
you're going to call that site as
homozygous against in both of those uh
and on both of those scaffolds and so
then you you just don't get the headers
I guess or the head calls and that is
kind of what I was seeing whenever I
looked at the uh
the heterozygosity rate
of these reads mapped to the reference
genomes that I was working with I I saw
a very low
uh
so I'll heterozygasty it was that was
much lower than I anticipated
and so
um
what I then need now is kind of
a way to kind of distinguish things that
are sequences Within These references
that are allelic to one another
um uh so that I can actually separate
these haplotypes out of the genome
um and so the approach that I wanted to
use was just to use sequence diversity
and so the way we can do that is we can
take this genome map it against itself
and then for each pair of contigs or
scaffolds that are aligning to each
other we can go across count the number
of snips count the number of line base
pairs and calculate the sequence
Divergence number from that that just
Snips over a line base pairs
and what you get is this really nice
bimodal distribution where things with
very low sequence Divergence are allelic
to one another and then everything on
the right side of this distribution are
have homology to one another but the
sequence Divergence is much higher and
the homology is more likely due to like
pass whole genome duplication events and
things like that
and so if I just disregard everything on
the right side of this distribution just
work with things that are showing low
sequence Divergence and I think our
allelic to one another but I can then do
is go across the genome and just
arbitrarily kind of Bin one of the two
into a haplotype one or a haplotype two
uh and then from there we can take this
heterozygous genome and kind of like
make a nice computational inbred just by
removing one of those haplotypes and so
then I can just do all of the read
mapping and variant calling against this
single haplotype and I should get an
accurate representation of the alleles
that are present in all the individuals
in the population
and so really
the whole thing is just to try to make
this this process with working with
trypscomb a little bit more analogous to
maze so that we can apply a lot of these
genetics and genomics methods that are
already established and uh and work
really well in maze to trypscomb
identify that freezing tolerance and
then bring it back
uh here's a little bit of evidence that
we we actually go outside occasionally
which is uh but but really I just want
to say thank you to all the people that
have really contributed to this project
and thank you to all the people in the
buckler lab Michelle and shinkai
postdocs in our lab have been really
really helpful uh
uh and from Iowa State Matt Hufford and
Iran they're responsible for assembling
the the reference genomes that that we
now can actually do mapping with which
is awesome and uh the Danforth Center
Elizabeth Kellogg and Taylor Aubuchon
Elder uh did all the like sampling of uh
of the Andrew pagonier from across the
world uh that have been sequenced and uh
of course my funding sources committee
members and yeah any questions
I
so I went through like the entire
process of mapping rates to the
reference genome uh and and and trying
to do uh
um uh better like resolution actual
mapping with with those with that data
but um
uh that's when I kind of ran into this
issue where a little frequency
distributions looked really strange and
and this was before I knew that we
really weren't doing a proper job of
separating out haplotypes from the
reference and so there was a lot of the
genome that just had uh both alleles
present and so I was missing a lot of
heterozygosity and so
it when I say it didn't work I mean like
there there wasn't really anything
interesting to see so so don't really
have candidates but
this is kind of a recent development
we're kind of going back through the
process now and then but yeah
okay so the question was did we see
structural polymorphisms between the two
haplotypes uh and added we pick which
one to keep for for uh mapping so
structural polymorphisms yeah so
um it's not going to be easy to see from
this there there is yeah there's a lot
of like inversions you'll see some
deletions between haplotypes
um uh but that didn't really go into a
whole lot of that wasn't
that wasn't very much that wasn't
considered really when when like bidding
things into haplotype one or two the
only thing that was actually considered
was the length of the uh the assembled
scaffold and so what I kept are just the
longer of the two pairs uh just to try
to the idea trying to be that it's
possible like like haplotype
or the longer one may have
uh some sequence that that's
going to need to be represented in in
the the final genome for mapping that
isn't in haplotype two so it's just the
longer one of the two
so the question was uh instead of
working with these heterozygous genomes
would it be
easier to to just
either make a trips come inbred or or
find one that is so uh the cool thing is
we we almost already do have one that is
pretty inbred it's so there were three
trip scams that were sequenced one of
them uh was strangely very inbred
already but there was still like
portions of the genome that did have
heterozygosity and were captured in the
reference um
but it the process of making like the
crosses
um is a little bit difficult and that's
kind of why we ended up with this uh
this structure where the f1s were open
pollinated instead of making making
control like cells
Sean Luke
yeah so the question
was
okay and make a computational reference
that has generous so kind of like
collapsing it and and maintaining
anything that was like deleted in one
versus the other kind of thing
um
are you thinking kind of like practical
haplotype graph kind of
okay
um I'm not sure I don't I don't really
I don't have a good idea for that I
guess
um but I think like that the like
problem about
the aligner not wanting to to like
resolve through a higher Divergence
region isn't necessarily an issue in
this case just because
um the way that I align these genomes
was using anchor wave which uh will
identify like large synthetic blocks and
then do more refined base pair
resolution alignment within those blocks
um and so
I think and then also like I only really
care about things that are low
Divergence in this case
uh and we're still capturing things that
are really high Divergence so
but yeah I could still be I'm not sure
that's a good question
okay are there any questions on Zoom or
all right cool thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu